[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre c'est un
fiasco depuis 2022 le président de la
République subit une crise
institutionnelle vous venez d'y ajouter
une crise politique majeure et inédite
en jouant sur les peurs le président de
la République attise les braises d'un
pays déjà incandescent
oui c'est
irresponsable votre Ministre aux
déclarations à géométrie variable a pris
sur lui l'entière charge du projet de
loi immigration il a échoué au travers
de son échec vous avez échoué et au
travers de votre échec c'est le
président de la République qui a échoué
à vouloir tromper tout le monde vous
n'avez convaincu personne vous avez
provoqué cette situation c'est à vous de
nous en sortir désormais mais puisque
vous écartez un nouvel article 49 alinéa
3 quelle sera l'ampleur de la
capitulation de la majorité présidence
en commission mixte paritaire quel sera
le prix du renoncement aux valeurs
républicaines la suppression de l'aide
médicale d'État la fin de la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension l'instauration d'une
préférence nationale madame la Première
ministre il est encore temps suivez
l'exemple du président rotillot retirez
votre projet de
loi madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur
monsieur le Président Patrick
canner lundi à l'Assemblée nationale vos
collègues députés socialiste ont pris
une décision lourde ils ont choisi de
mêler leur voix à celle de l'extrême
droite pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats au
Parlement
ils ont choisi de refuser d'exercer leur
mission de parlementaire discuter et
voter la loi je me souviens d'un temps
où le parti socialiste portait des
combats et des valeurs d'un temps où il
défendait avec force le Parlement le
Parti socialiste était un parti de
gouvernement à l'Assemblée de plus en
plus il s'enferme dans
l'obstruction monsieur le Président
canner je connais la sincérité de vos
convictions
je connais votre attachement à la
démocratie parlementaire alors je vous
le demande avec vos collègues sénateurs
socialiste allez-vous laisser le Parti
socialiste se dissoudre au sein de
l'anupes
allez-vous allez-vous le laisser sans
rien dire devenir un satellite de la
France insoumise et vootter avec le
rassemblement national où comptez-vous
sauver l'honneur du parti socialiste
défendre ce qui fait son histoire et ses
valeurs en attendant avec mon
gouvernement nous ne laisserons jamais
les manœuvres politiciennes l'emporter
les Français attendent des solutions ils
demandent des mesures fortes face à
l'immigration illégale il souhaite que
nous travaillons pour une meilleure
intégration de ceux que nous accueillons
avec le ministre de l'intérieur c'est ce
que nous sommes déterminés à faire une
commission mixte paritaire se tiendra
lundi nous sommes résolus à apporter des
réponses nos concitoyens avec mon
gouvernement nous choisirons toujours la
voix de la responsabilité et le chemin
de l'action je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
[Applaudissements]
caner madame la Premier ministre je vous
ai posé une question de fond vous MZ
poser de manière
politicienne
le vous connaissez vous connaissez la
locution latine bien connu des juristes
nul ne peut se prévaloir de sa propre
turpitude excusez-moi de vous rappeler
que le 14 novembre ici les sénateurs de
votre groupe majoritaire à quelques
exceptions ont voté le texte de la
droite sénatoriale avec toutes les
suppressions que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure
alors je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir au
nom de mon
groupe ne laissez pas vos députés
Renaissance se dissoudre parmi les
députés et
disol mêm dans les groupes de la
République de la du rassemblement
national voilà la réalité voilà la
réalité qui est posé madame ministre
reti votre texte